[Música]
salió de la planta a su hostal el que
podría ser el último bastión de los
ucranianos en mariupol más de 260
militares están bajo el poder ruso en la
región de donges que es como quiere
juzgarlos pero quien aspira a un canje
por prisioneros de guerra
el presidente estadounidense joe biden
visitó la ciudad de buffalo en el estado
de nueva york quien le rindió un
homenaje a las diez víctimas mortales
que dejó el tiroteo del sábado en la
conmemoración el mandatario afirmó que
la supremacía blanca es un veneno
eeuu suaviza las sanciones contra
venezuela para facilitar los diálogos
entre el gobierno de nicolás maduro y la
oposición caracas respondió que espera
que todas las presiones se levanten
mientras que la plataforma unitaria
afirma que hay acercamientos para
reiniciar la negociación en méxico
tenemos reporte desde caracas
bienvenidos a este informativo de france
24 mi nombre es maría clara calle e
iniciamos con las noticias en ucrania
cerca de 265 combatientes del regimiento
asof salieron de la planta de asof tal
donde está el último bastión de la
resistencia en mariupol ellos fueron
trasladados hacia don yesca a una zona
controlada por separatistas pro rusos
moscú habla de rendición pero kiev
espera que haya un canje por prisioneros
de guerra su parte las autoridades
ucranianas aseguran que todavía hay
personas dentro de la planta pero no
precisaron cuántas y la importancia de
esta fábrica es que si cae mariupol se
convertiría en la ciudad más grande que
ha tomado moscú desde el inicio de la
invasión el reporte lo tiene ariana
villacorta en siete buses partieron los
combatientes ucranianos que resistieron
durante semanas al asedio ruso dentro
del complejo de as hostal en mariupol su
destino zonas bajo el control de los
rusos en lo que rusia calificó de
rendición masiva
ayer comenzó la rendición de los
militantes de la unidad nacionalista los
soldados ucranianos bloqueados en la
planta 2 talent mariupol en las últimas
24 horas 265 militantes depusieron las
armas y se rindieron incluidos 51
heridos graves
el presidente de la cámara baja del
parlamento ruso se refirió a ellos como
criminales de guerra mientras que la
vice primera ministra de ucrania aseguró
que la operación fue una evacuación
coordinada con el enemigo y que aspiraba
a un intercambio de prisioneros
como nosotros por nuestra parte podemos
decir que el proceso de negociación está
en marcha y que la propia operación de
rescate está en marcha
para el gobierno la resistencia en el
puerto hasta hoy fue fundamental en el
curso de la guerra
y la defensa sostenida por nuestros
defensores de mariupol no permitió que
el enemigo redistribuyeran sus fuerzas
alrededor de 20.000 efectivos
toni como el enemigo no pudo
redistribuirse a otras regiones y no fue
capaz de capturar rápidamente a la
policía
[Música]
por eso aunque simbólica la resistencia
de asos tal no supuso mucha diferencia
para los bandos porque rusia había
trasladado la mayor parte de sus fuerzas
desde mariupol hace semanas
en este punto para los ucranianos las
fuerzas en mariupol habían hecho su
trabajo no había mucho más que pudieran
hacer
se desconoce cuántas personas podrían
permanecer en las ruinas de la sería
fortificada de 11 kilómetros cuadrados
pero quien dijo que se concentrará en
sacarlos con vida
el miércoles suecia y finlandia
entregarán formalmente su solicitud para
unirse a la otan y el jueves la primera
ministra sueca magdalena adversión y el
presidente finlandés hui lin y isto
viajarán a washington para reunirse con
el presidente estadounidense joe biden
la casa blanca afirmó que confiaba en
que los países miembros de la otan
llegaran a un consenso para aceptar a
las naciones nórdicas y es que el
mandatario de turquía recep tayib
erdogán dijo que se opondría y acusó a
los dos países de albergar militantes
del partido de los trabajadores del
kurdistán la decisión de la alianza
militar tiene que ser unánime y suecia y
finlandia esperan el respaldo a suecia
también quiere cooperar con turquía
dentro de la otan ya
esta cooperación puede ser un elemento
nuevo e importante en nuestras
relaciones bilaterales
por supuesto suecia se opone a todas las
formas de terrorismo al igual que la
otan y la unión europea no todos turbo
com ampliar el derecho al aborto y los
derechos sexuales de las mujeres es lo
que puede ocurrir en españa este martes
se cumplió el primer paso que fue la
aprobación del anteproyecto de ley por
parte del consejo de ministros pero aún
falta la revisión del poder judicial del
consejo de estado y de los legisladores
una de las reformas permitiría que las
jóvenes puedan abortar a partir de los
16 años sin el permiso de sus padres
aunque se quedó por fuera uno de los
temas más pedidos rebajar el iva de los
productos de higiene femenina desde
madrid' nuestra corresponsal marina
colorado nos explicó previamente los
puntos clave de la reforma que impulsa
el gobierno español
en españa es legal abortar desde
1985 pero mientras que esa primera ley
solo lo permitía en tres supuestos la
actual ley de 2010 ampliaba esta opción
a cualquier persona hasta la semana 14
la reforma que ha aprobado el consejo de
ministros del gobierno de españa y que
ha anunciado la ministra de igualdad
irene montero ataviada con un pañuelo
verde a la muñeca incluye algunas
novedades recupera el derecho de que
jóvenes de 16 y 17 años y mujeres con
discapacidad puedan abortar sin permiso
de sus progenitores o tutores legales
también elimina las 72 horas de
reflexión obligatorias en vigor en este
momento y regula la objeción de
conciencia para que siempre haya
personal disponible para practicar
abortos en las clínicas públicas ya que
debido a la objeción el 85 por ciento de
estas prácticas se deriva a clínicas
acreditadas privadas españa podría ser
un pionero en europa al reconocer bajas
laborales por menstruaciones dolorosas o
incapacitante es una práctica que ya
existe sobre todo en asia la reforma
también incorpora una baja de preparto
desde la semana 39 de embarazo que no
influye en la bajada y lo que no quedó
en el texto fue la reducción al 4 de
oliva a los productos de higiene
femenina que serán repartidos gratis así
como anticonceptivos de barrera en
centros de educación secundaria de salud
y prisiones y pretende incluir la
educación sexual desde etapas tempranas
de la infancia debido a la complejidad
del anteproyecto de ley y la diversidad
de los ministerios involucrados es
posible que esta ley no vea la luz hasta
el año que viene hasta 2023
y pasamos américa el presidente
estadounidense joe biden visitó la
ciudad de buffalo en el estado de nueva
york donde el sábado un joven mató a 10
personas e hirió a tres más 11 de ellas
eran afroamericanas antes de rendirle un
homenaje a las víctimas del tiroteo
masivo el mandatario afirmó que se trató
de un acto de terrorismo doméstico y
criticó el supremacismo blanco en el
país a mal vernos mantiene la historia
el supremacismo blanco es un veneno el
software es un veneno realmente que se
está extendiendo por nuestro cuerpo
político y hemos permitido que se agrave
y crezca ante nuestros ojos
ya es suficiente amor estas fueron las
palabras con las que el presidente de
estados unidos joe biden condenó el
tiroteo que cobró la vida de 10 personas
en la localidad de buffalo en el estado
de nueva york
by then se solidarizó con las familias
de las víctimas y calificó el ataque
armado que es investigado como un crimen
de odio de terrorismo por repetir lo que
ocurrió aquí es simple y sencillo es
terrorismo
y el terrorismo terrorismo doméstico
según medios de comunicación locales que
revisaron cientos de mensajes del
asesino en internet el acto fue
meticulosamente planificado durante
meses el sábado 14 de mayo el agresor
condujo por más de 3 horas desde su
pueblo hasta el topes friendly market en
un barrio afroamericano de búfalo
vestido con ropa de combate el
perpetrador llevaba un arma
semiautomática con la que asesinó a 10
personas e hirió a otras 3 11 de las
víctimas serán afrodescendientes el
tirador está acusado de asesinato
premeditado y deberá comparecer ante el
juez el jueves la tragedia ha vuelto a
suscitar un debate sobre el control a la
venta de armas en el país by then
aseguró que pedirá al congreso tomar
medidas para prohibir que las personas
con enfermedades mentales adquieran
armas y es que según el archivo de
violencia armada en lo que va del 2022
se han registrado en el país al menos
198 tiroteos masivos
a propósito de eeuu a este país suavizó
una de las sanciones contra venezuela y
le permitió a la petrolera
estadounidense chevron iniciar
conversaciones con el gobierno de
nicolás maduro y también con la compañía
estatal pedevesa aunque chevron todavía
no podrá operar en suelo venezolano
washington sostiene que la medida es
para facilitar las negociaciones entre
la administración y los opositores
reunidos en la plataforma unitaria
nuestra corresponsal daniela zambrano
nos dio todos los detalles desde caracas
una de las primeras reacciones fue la de
la vicepresidenta del si rodríguez a
través de 'twitter' quien decía esperar
que éste fuera un camino para que se
levantaran todas las sanciones impuestas
contra venezuela' y confirmaba que el
gobierno de eeuu permitiría la
comercialización por parte de empresas
tanto europeas como estadounidenses con
la estatal petróleos de venezuela sin
embargo vale la pena destacar que
trascendió más temprano que el
levantamiento de estas sanciones incluía
que chevron pudiese reanudar
conversaciones con la estatal petróleos
de venezuela sin embargo no se
especificaba que pudiesen comercializar
el crudo
venezolano luego se conoció un
comunicado que difundió la denominada
plataforma unitaria la coalición de
partidos opositores en el que anunciaban
que formalmente se reanudaban las
conversaciones con el gobierno de
nicolás maduro para reactivar el diálogo
en méxico también se difundió una
fotografía con los jefes negociadores de
ambos bandos estrechándose las manos
jorge rodríguez y gerardo blyde con el
mismo mensaje vale la pena destacar que
por parte del gobierno de eeuu el asesor
de la casa blanca para américa latina
aseguraba que sí estaban aliviando las
sanciones en venezuela para que se
renovará el diálogo en pro de buscar
unas elecciones libres y transparentes
pero que estas sanciones podrían volver
a ser impuestas en caso de que no
avanzaran esas negociaciones la cumbre
de las américas no contará con la
presencia de otro presidente y es que
hoy el mandatario de guatemala alejandro
giammattei anunció que no acudirá a la
reunión que se realizará en los ángeles
en junio previamente sus homólogos de
méxico y de bolivia andrés manuel lópez
obrador y luis arce afirmaron que
tampoco irían si eeuu se mantiene en su
postura de no invitar a cuba venezuela y
nicaragua además el anuncio de llama
'the y se produjo un día después de que
washington criticara la designación de
consuelo porras como la fiscal general
de guatemala y es que ella está en la
lista del departamento de estado
estadounidense sobre agentes corruptos
las tormentas de arena azotan a varios
países árabes de la región del golfo
pérsico las espesas nubes de polvo han
cubierto a la ciudad de kuwait capital
del país que lleva el mismo nombre un
escenario similar se ha visto en doha
qatar y en riad la capital saudí pero el
más afectado de todos ha sido irak allí
la crisis climática ha agravado la
sequía a un punto en el que las
tormentas de arena se han vuelto tan
comunes en las últimas semanas ha habido
una cada dos o tres días
de hecho en bagdad la capital unas 4000
personas tuvieron que acudir a
hospitales por problemas respiratorios
y terminamos con noticias culturales
porque se inauguró el festival de cine
de cannes el martes varias estrellas
desfilaron por la alfombra roja de esta
edición número 75 y el glamour volvió al
resort de la riviera francesa cuando el
evento se realiza en plena normalidad
luego de más de dos años de pandemia al
final de 12 días de proyecciones y
festividades se conocerá el o la
ganadora de la famosa palma de oro
gabriel colchón tiene los detalles este
martes estrellas internacionales
desfilaron en la famosa alfombra roja
del festival de cannes entre las cuales
estuvieron eva longoria o mandrin o
julianne moore que oficialmente abrió la
edición 75 del festival internacional de
cine el regla declaró abierta a la
edición 75 del festival de cannes música
el actor francés consoló london que
participó en la película titán ganadora
de la palma de oro el año pasado
calificó el cine de arma de emoción
masiva el presidirá el jurado compuesto
de otros ocho miembros tomando su papel
en serio como explicó en una rueda de
prensa la suele vender la única manera
de intentarlo es volviendo a ser un
espectador el que eras cuando eras niño
es decir ver películas e intentar que
pasen por tu corazón antes de que vayan
a tu cerebro esperar las emociones
intentar captar las llegar sin ideas
preconcebidas un equipo estoy
simplemente encantado y encantado de
compartir este momento con las 8
personas que me rodean
con motivo de la ceremonia de
inauguración el festival rindió homenaje
al actor forest whitaker el presidente
del festival real y esquiú le entregó
una palma de honor por su trayectoria lo
que le provocó una gran ovación
en pando enero que iba a la fue a lápiz
una pole honor que va a la artista al
cineasta al embajador de la unesco y
simplemente a un ciudadano del mundo
veintiuna películas están en competición
oficial para ganar la famosa palma de
oro en una edición particularmente
marcada por la guerra en ucrania
llegamos al final de las noticias en
france 24 los invitamos a que vean
nuestra señal en vivo en nuestro canal
de youtube donde estamos las 24 horas
nos vemos
[Música]